[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous alors moi
c'est antoine et je m'appelle théo et on
est très heureux d'enfin sortir de nos
15 mètre carré parisien pour rejoindre
notre belle ville d'orléans ça fait pas
mal d'années que notre vie est rythmée
par une expression salvatrice vous savez
le genre d'expression qui vous permet de
passer une meilleure journée trois
petits mots qui changent absolument tout
cette expression qui vous permet de
rester sur le canapé sans aucune
culpabilité de ne pas sortir les
poubelles de ne pas passer l'aspirateur
ou de ne pas remplir votre déclaration
de revenus
commencent à tapas passer l'aspirateur
étape à sortir les poubelles
franchement on verra demain demain
demain demain comme la préparation de ce
tête qu'on à procrastiner cessa
procrastiner mois vous y croyez vraiment
non je suis pas flemmards j'optimise
juste montant ok alors déjà qui t'a dit
que procrastinateurs voulait dire
flemmard même si on a souvent tendance à
penser ça comme ça toi comme moi on sait
que c'est beaucoup plus complexe ok donc
notre mission d'aujourd'hui c'est de
clarifier ce quiproquo
procrastiner ne veut pas dire glander et
donc pour une fois dans notre lit on a
décidé de sortir de notre canapé pour
aller faire des recherches par endroit
le plus hype de tout en relayant la
médiathèque et ça nous a amenés
à nous lancer dans le livre de référence
à savoir le petit robert il disait quoi
le petit robert sur la procrastination
d'ailleurs et coûte rien de plus simple
en fait ça signifie littéralement
remettre tout lendemain eh ouais
étymologiquement parlant le mot
procrastination est une combinaison du
mot pro qui signifie vers l'avant et
kras thynnus signifiant appartenant à
demain puis de fil en aiguille on en est
arrivé à s'intéresser à l'origine
historique de la procrastination est en
fait il faut savoir que les premières
définition de la procrastination remonte
de l'egypte jusqu'à la grèce antique où
il parle de procrastination est
effectivement mais sans en mentionner ce
terme exact à ce moment là il faisait
plutôt référence à des personnes malines
qui s'arrangeait pour fuir les tâches en
plus inutile quoi en soit il faisait
vraiment la différence avec les vrais
flemmards qui ne font strictement rien
mais du coup quand est-ce qu'on a eu ses
premières définition c'est première
utilisation du mot procrastination c'est
bien plus tard que nos procrastination
c'est un peu officialisé avec les
edwards holtz chronicles en soit dans
cette oeuvre du 16e siècle on y trouve
plusieurs occurrences du mot
procrastination mais dans sa version
anglaise et c'était quoi un
procrastinateurs au xvième siècle il y
avait une petite nuance n'hésitez pas
seulement un flemmard c'est quelqu'un de
malins qu'ils savaient quel point il
était bon de s'investir dans un projet
quand il valait mieux déguerpir elle
rien faire
d'ailleurs en parlant du 16e siècle tu
le savais qu'il y avait des traces de
procrastination dans des sermons
religieux tu peux nous en dire plus a
pour résumer parler un peu de satan il
dit que satan nous mène tout et tous
vers la procrastination pour l'éviter on
devrait plutôt se tourner vers dieu
sacré méthode pour arrêter de
procrastiner quoi et c'est au xviiie
siècle que tout change en pleine
révolution industrielle le
procrastinateur de gameplay une plie à
wind plein plaie pour la société en fait
c'est à ce moment là que naît la
définition de la procrastination
reconnaît aujourd'hui pourquoi tu crois
vraiment qu'on te laisser remettre les
choses au lendemain quand tout le monde
travaillait d'arrache-pied lusine nous
ne t 15 heures par jour minimum de
travail je pense à l'époque et depuis
18e il s'est passé quoi au juste allez
petit quiz est ce que vous connaissez la
personne qui représentait les droits de
l'homme aux états unis
sous
charles luther king exactement avait lui
il y avait la sage est représentée par
gandhi et la procrastination par oblomov
oblomov le pire colocataires que vous
pouvez avoir dans votre vie le mec est
quand même resté affalé sur son divan
pendant plus de dix ans c'était la
caricature même de l'aristocratie russe
est ce que vous saviez que cet homme
russe a quand même un mot français à son
nom un mot français loblaw mot wismes c1
peu comme de la procrastination c'est
comme si vous mélangez l'apathie la
léthargie l'inertie l'engourdissement la
rêverie en fait tout ce qui peut se
manifester dans l'horreur du travail les
peuples à l'image de la procrastination
quoi après tu as quand même plusieurs
explications scientifiques à tout ça
j'imagine que tu peux nous en dire plus
bas de manière simplifiée voilà comment
fonctionne le cerveau d'un nom
procrastinateurs on a cette fameuse
intentions d'un côté vous savez du type
et mec demain j'arrête le mcdo je te
jure et j'ai vu qu'il y avait des offres
là la salle de sport donc demain je me
mets tu m'avais aussi dit demain pour la
préparation de ce fait non bref des
intentions du quotidien vous l'auriez
compris et de l'autre côté on à l'action
c'est à dire le fait de vraiment
réaliser ces tâches alors ça va
peut-être vous paraître fou mais ce
passage de l'intention à l'action ne
dépend pas que de notre motivation dans
notre cerveau au niveau du lobe
préfrontal se trouve le qg de la
fonction exécutive pour faire simple
c'est à cet endroit que se trouve le
bouton magique qui permet de passer de
l'intention
à l'action petit spoiler ne cherchez pas
appuyer dessus ça fonctionne pas nous
fait vraiment pas mal s'il vous plaît
envoie pas le bc ce soit bon plus
sérieusement cette fameuse étude et ce
fameux bouton en fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'amygdale et selon sa taille
vous aurez plus ou moins de mal à vous
mettre au travail c'est toujours une
question de taille ça
avance qui aurait enlevé mais tu qu il
se passe quoi quand tu as une grosse
amygdales et bien tu sera amené à
procrastiner beaucoup plus facilement et
c'est d'ailleurs très exactement ce qui
a été prouvé par des bio psychologue de
la cour universitat pour vous en
allemagne quoi voilà vous l'aurez
compris la paf est allemand levait 2
mais auriez aussi compris que lorsque
vous procrastiner la prochaine fois faut
dire que vous avez une grosse amygdales
ok
donc ça c'est la procrastination d'un
point de vue scientifique
mais du côté sociologique ça donne quoi
bon on va encore déconstruire les
clichés je suis désolé de vous
l'annoncer et antoine sera totalement
d'accord avec moi sur ce sujet je pense
que vous êtes toutes et tous des
procrastinateurs dans cette salle en
fait quand tu es au 10 à ce qu'il veut
dire par là c'est quand on parle de
procrastination on peut parler de
différents types de procrastinateurs et
ya notamment les recherches du docteur
linda sabbadin qui en a identifié
plusieurs types bien distincts mais
surtout surtout bien loin du cliché du
gros flemmard on va vous présenter trois
situations correspondant à trois types
de procrastinateurs différents que vous
avez peut-être vécu une fois dix fois
voire même plus pour les plus
procrastinateurs d'entre vous pour
simplifier la chose on va vous raconter
l'histoire de bob
voici bob
il est mignon
bob comme tout bon étudiant s'est perdu
sur internet en voulant faire des
recherches sur ce sujet ça ça illustre
hyper bien menti favori le rêveur celui
qui est hyper curieux il s'intéresse à
tellement de sujets que finalement il
fait jamais ce qu'il faut à l'instant t
et son pire ennemi les listes de tâches
un rêveur finit toujours par ajouter des
tâches inutiles à sa liste afin de se
berner lui-même son objectif
c'est-à-dire la fin de la journée ah je
suis quand même bien travaillé
aujourd'hui
sauf que sauf que là d'un coup s'en
privèrent le père de bob rentrer dans sa
chambre et lui demande de la rangée pour
la troisième fois de la semaine mais
rassurez vous bob a la solution quelques
petits mots qui font la différence je le
ferai demain ça va je vais le faire ce
type d'expression que tout le monde a
déjà entendu et caractéristique typique
du type de procrastinateurs qu'on
appelle le rebelle celui qui est
incapable de faire quoi que ce soit dès
lors qu'il y ait un tant soit peu
contraint et ça ne se limite pas qu'aux
adolescents vous voit les adultes dans
la salle
bon après bobby fait quoi et bien bob
avait un devoir maison à faire il y
avait plusieurs semaines pour le faire
donc ça va sauf que encore une fois
il a attendu la veille pour s'y mettre
il disait même et je cite en vrai ça va
je te rassure j'ai le temps
franchement je ferai ça juste avant
caractéristique typique du troisième
cycle celui qui est aime travailler sous
pression celui qui attend vraiment
vraiment le dernier moment pour se
mettre au travail ça me rappelle quelque
chose ton histoire
comme nous avec ce tête maintenant nous
ne sommes pas baup théo
bon après au delà linda sabbadin qui
caractérise les procrastinateurs en
différents types il ya les chercheurs
canadiens choo et shui un peu
procrastinateurs sur les bords qui eux
ne se seront pas du tout embêté en fait
pour eux il ya les actifs est allé
passif
autrement dit les actifs sont ceux qui
procrastine mais qui sont productifs sur
d'autres sujets à côté ça c'est ce qu'on
peut appeler les vrais procrastinateurs
d'ailleurs les hyperactifs font souvent
partie de cette catégorie car ils ont
tendance à se lancer dans divers sujets
mais sans jamais aller jusqu'au bout et
de l'autre côté on a donc les passifs
qui sont donc les vrais glandeurs
cette petite différence entre glandeurs
et pour christina teurs s'explique au
travers de la sensibilité de chacun au
plaisir immédiat sur le chercheur
psychologue timothy piscine de
l'université de carleton en fait selon
lui ou préfère éviter le stress et les
émotions négatives il ya certaines
tâches comme la donc résultats en
progression bon on a hésité à nous
arrêter là on a une troisième et
dernière idée afin de vous aider à
déculpabiliser de l'appréciation et si
cette fois ci on vous disait que la
procrastination
était génétique
désolé c'est ce qu'a tenté de trouver
une étude de chercheurs de la vanderbilt
university en 2014 ont par contre lui
l'a fait ongles elle vient pas au bon
plus sérieusement cette fameuse étude a
permis définir que pour plus d'un cas
sur deux la procrastination
était bel et bien d'un héritage familial
merci papa merci maman
d'ailleurs s'il ya des descendants de
léonard de vinci dans la salle vous
devez être sacré procrastinateurs
avant de vous expliquer leur en veux en
venir il faut savoir qu'il ya énormément
de jeunes historique d'artistes qui sont
identifiés comme étant de vous
formidable pour christina teurs ce que
tu veux dire par là c'est que ça
démontre bien qu'on peut être
programmateur et avoir du génie par la
même occasion léonard de vinci mozart
victor hugo et tant d'autres
nous sommes toutes et tous des
procrastinateurs on commence avec
l'honneur de 20 si tu ne racontes tout
le monde connaît cette figure est
représenté à elle seule la période de la
renaissance italienne on le connaît tout
particulièrement pour ses peintures tels
que la joconde ou encore la scène
représentant le dernier repas du christ
mais léonard était un expert dans de
multiples domaines je te laisse les
sites et
les mathématiques l'anatomie urbanis
l'hydraulique l'art militaire
l'ingénierie le chant la sculpture la
peinture la poésie
mouvement est là
bref il aurait pu en faire des ted mais
ce qui est moins connu c'est que léonard
était un formidable procrastinateurs
c'était l'incarnation de la curiosité à
outrance il s'intéressait à tellement
domaine qui s'arrêtait régulièrement au
pleine production pour
remettre plus tard on jamais tu veux
dire pas loin parce qu'elles vont pas
loin par exemple il a mis plus d'une
vingtaine d'années a terni la joconde
tableau qui l'a d'ailleurs jamais rendu
même chose pour une statue qui l'a tout
simplement pas rendu où plus d'une
quinzaine d'années pour une famille
italienne reconnu cet homme était un
maître dans une dizaine d'art dont la
procrastination d'ailleurs même chose
pour mozart est ce que vous saviez que
la veille de l'opéra de giovanni la
première
l'introduction à cet opéra manquait
d'ailleurs c'est pas parce qu'il faisait
que de bord du punch avec sa femme il ya
bien une histoire comme ça petite
anecdote elle l'a réveillé vers 5 heures
du matin en pleine gueule de bois car il
s'est souvenu qu'il avait tout
simplement oublié d'écrire l'ouverture
en question puis deux heures plus tard
mozart l'a écrite et la remise à l'opéra
d'ailleurs elle a pas mal surpris le
public puisse qu'on soit ils s'attendent
à une ouverture plutôt heureuse mais dès
le début les choix de lancer une fin
tragique et comme on connaît tous le
succès de cette oeuvre comme quoi la
procrastination salut prouve mais
l'histoire et victor hugo c'était quoi
c'est un peu cocasse
lui ce qu'il avait l'angoissé de la page
blanche
lorsqu'il devait écrire notre dame de
paris le problème quand ils procrastiner
c'est qu'il batifoler un peu partout
le souci c'est que la maison d'édition
lui demander des comptes car les délais
étaient totalement dépassé il a trouvé
une solution à tout ça la figure top oui
en fait il rentrait chez lui est retiré
tous ses vêtements sur son caleçon
il mettait tous ses vêtements dans un
tiroir fermé à clé jeté la clé et ne
pouvait donc plus sortir de chez lui ça
c'est habile c'est vraiment habile il
pouvait pas sortir de chez lui gales
donc les objets se mettre au travail
exactement excellent
temps à autre des solutions pour arrêter
procrastiner des solutions qu'on
pourrait partager à toutes et tous
aujourd'hui ouais comme par exemple les
listes de tâches rpt a parlé tout à
l'heure on fait une liste de choses à
faire et une fois qu'elles sont
effectués en les coches way simple
efficace après il faut être honnête avec
soi-même à se lever du matin c'est pas
une tâche en soit je ne t'ai pas
convaincu et on a aussi pomodoro 25
minutes de travail a senti intensifs
puis cinq minutes de pause ouais par
l'inversion
bon soin ces solutions ne sont pas
magiques il faut que chacun s'est
approprié trouve son équilibre ce que tu
veux dire par là c'est que certaines
solutions fonctionnent bien avec
certaines personnes alors que d'autres
pas du tout j'imagine que tu as un truc
à nous raconter oui clairement merci tu
parais des to do list pour moi c'est
plus un moyen trop cas ci n'est qu'autre
chose
je prends le temps de fermat à toulouse
quand ça arrive je la regarde j'en suis
fier l'épée est là et bien structuré
je regarde elle me regarde
on se regarde
pour qu'au final je ne la suive pas du
tout et que je fasse tout autre chose ce
mois ci en soit la vraie question qu'on
voudrait tout se poser et tous se poser
c'est pas pourquoi n'apprenons tout
simplement nous pas à vivre avec notre
programme six nations on vous a donné un
certain nombre d' excuse mais vous n'en
avez pas nécessairement besoin
la procrastination aussi des points
positifs il n'ya pas se sentir coupable
de la procrastination c'est se faire
plaisir
prendre le temps
profiter juste
ne devenez pas de sinistres glandeurs
s'il vous plaît
soit on avait pensé à faire une vraie
conclusion
je vous jure
mais franchement on verra demain
[Applaudissements]